bon je vous parle d'un truc qui me fait
pas trop rires vous vous dire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'étais à plusieurs
événements presse j'ai passé la journée
à déplacer entre un événement rouillen
de poules ce matin il ya eu ensuite bits
les casques il ya eu ensuite des lilly a
eu ensuite philippe chow il est aussi co
d'ailleurs un train plein de trucs supra
coule donc on va en parler ça vous
intéresse qu on en parle de ce casque de
beats qui a déjà sorti c'est le studio 3
wireless vous ai parlé d'un autre casque
beats et pas longtemps ça vous intéresse
pas le seul a dit le mois ils viennent
le récupérer
bill stone d'affilée donc ça c'est
vachement cool produit aussi intéressant
alors ça c'est génial c'est pour la déco
du studio des ampoules qu'il est
directement chez félix cardenas truc-là
pas si vous voyez bien ça la cfs donc tu
roules torsades filaments ça va être
juste qu'elle lessing pour la déco du
studio ça c'est des lampes un peu
vintage c'est vachement bien ce qu'ils
font du côté de chez philip sion passe
une langue vous allez vous allumez votre
interrupteurs et vous avez trois
ambiances différentes le truc est
vachement vachement bien donc j'ai des
trucs supra supra cool de ce côté là
et puis ensuite un smartphone dites moi
si ça vous de vote qu'on en parle j'ai
pas testé suire c'est le we call view 3
alors le vu trois a special edition ça
tout nouveau modèle qu'ils ont montré ce
soir
alors c'est le vieux troyes on reste
roland dieu 3 c'est toujours le même
modèle et la différence que vous avez
avec celui là c'est que vous avez un dos
je crois que c'est le dos ou alors
est-ce une coque qui rament by veut
travailler avec des artistes
il ya trois créations différentes moi
j'ai choisi celle là parce qu'une semble
qu'elle passera beaucoup mieux en vidéo
que les deux hommes mettront tout aussi
sympa fait juste jeter un coup d'oeil
parce que c'est vous avez des stickers
du créateur c'est vachement sympa non
c'est pas le smartphone heinz et ça
c'est pas de smartphone c'est le vieux 3
mais je pense que c'est la coque que je
dois avoir quelque part à l'intérieur
qui elle
voilà c'est la coque qui à la créa et
qui du coup une fois misé sur le view 3
vous fait un vieux troyes special
edition sans permis à mikko de faire
parler un petit peu de en cette fin
d'année pourquoi pas ça pas vous
associer à des créateurs le
rendu est assez sympa c'est pas mal
c'est ainsi qualitatif je trouve ça
original c'est plutôt bien en tout cas
qui cherche à faire quelque chose là
dessus voilà et qu'est-ce que j'ai
d'autres c'est un calepin carnet créé
par l'artiste par l'artiste c'est tout
mignon
regardez les pages de l'intérieur séoul
a ici là il ya différentes créa c'est
pas mal c'est assez original
bon ça c'est cool mais c'est pas ça dont
je voulais vous parler je vais vous
parler en fait un truc qui m'est arrivé
et qui pose problème
aussi bien pour moi que pour vous à
savoir que des petits malins qui ont
usurpé nous les entités qui ont volé mon
identité sur instagram alors ça commence
sur un stade mais j'imagine que si on
part sur le délire de ces mecs là ça ira
beaucoup plus loin
pour tout vous dire aujourd'hui j'ai pas
prévu du tout de vous parler de ça je
voulais vous parler de ce sont les vous
parler d'iphone je voulais vous parler
de cet iphone là aujourd'hui et pas du
tout ça mais du coup bon on décale un
petit peu tout ça pour vous en parler
tout simplement parce que ces petits
malins là je vais vous montrer un dans
mon j'ai fait des captures d'écran ces
petits malins là ont tout simplement
envoyer des messages à plein de
personnes qui sont dans mon qui me
suivent sur instagram puisque la liste
et public en enrayant message suivant
félicitations vous êtes chanceux cette
semaine tu es parmi les gagnants vous
êtes sélectionné parmi les 150 premiers
fans à gagner un iphone 10 ou 11 pro tu
veux choisir quelle couleur s'est gavé
de fautes en plus gold argent noir nana
na na hey tu veux qu'elle capacités
voilà donc l'idée j'ai voilà le message
et il envoie bien évidemment à partir
d'un faux compte si vous cherchez sur
instagram
oui tous les faux comptes que les mecs
on crée alors le tout premier en hausse
et moi monsieur underscore groupe cémoi
en dessous vous avez les autres comptes
créés par les mecs vous avez monsieur
douzaine d'heures score greu vous avez
aussi underscore monsieur under the gang
re tout ça c'est pas moi points sauf au
niveau des onze mille et quelques
abonnés sur instagram
donc si vous voyez des contamines
abonnés sachez que c'est pas moi il faut
pas du tout jeune il faut pas répondre à
ces gens là et au contraire je vous
demande quelque chose et je vous le
demande
sagement se pouvait faire si vous êtes
sur sa gamme ça serait vraiment bien
qu'en fait c'est que vous avez sur
instagram dans la barre de recherche
vous tapez monsieur greu vous avez mon
compte monsieur underscore grenat onze
mille et quelques abonnés passez-moi les
comptes qui ne rend pas mes comptes à
moi vous allez dessus vous cliquez et
voulait signer
les comme ça instagram les freins
dégageaient directement alors je doute
pas que les personnes qui sont mal
intentionnées recommenceront et en
créant d'autres mais à chaque fois il
faut qu'on ait cette mécanique à pour
progresser primé pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est pas tant
par rapport à moi c'est plus par rapport
à vous parce que j'imagine que parmi
vous il ya des personnes qui vont pas
forcément vérifier que ça vient de mon
comté qui disent ah ah [ __ ] j'ai gagné
un truc c c'est super cool suis très
content du coup je clique et qu'est ce
que ces personnes vous demandez derrière
elles vont chercher à récupérer des
infos personnelles sur vous et j'imagine
que c'est de l'arnaqué à la carte bleue
pour récupérer bien j'en aie aie aie
vont probablement vous demander de faire
un virement de 1 euro
je ne sais pas quoi quelle connerie pour
pouvoir récupérer vos codes de carte
bleue alors j'imagine que la plupart
d'entre vous se feront pas avoir bien là
qui peuvent se faire avoir et c'est très
important de signaler ces gens là pour
que justement ça ça n'arrive pas donc ça
ne vous pénalise pas ça c'est vraiment
extrêmement important le deuxième point
c'est effectivement pour moi c'est des
gens qui usent jour mon identité qui
veulent mon identité numérique au niveau
de la marque pour effectivement pouvoir
faire des choses frauduleuse directement
avec le plus ses vis-à-vis de vous et
vis-à-vis des personnes qui ont cherché
à vous arnaquer avoue prendre de
l'argent en se faisant passer pour moi
ça c'est vraiment lui qui me pose
problème donc si vous pouvez aller sur
instagram faire la recherche
monsieur grenet tous les comptes qui ne
sont pas bons comptes à moi eh bien vous
les signalent tout petit on est onze
mille sept cents et quelques abonnés
vous reconnaîtrez aussi mon cours parce
que vous avez les petites story l'année
enregistrés en bas et que eux ne peuvent
pas avoir et non pas ils ont recopié
exactement le texte donc piqué ma photo
ils n'ont pas le nombre d'abonnés ils
ont pas la story vous verrez vraiment ça
à la différence j'ai fait la demande
d'avoir un compte certifié instagram sur
instagram justement évoqué le petit
badge qu'on puisse le reconnaître pour
l'instant ta g n'a pas donné suite
j'espère que ça va le faire je vais
relancer un peu le truc pour
qu'effectivement ça puisse pas
recommencer à l'avenir parce que
j'imagine que ces gens là vont
recommencer alors ils l'ont fait sur
instagram j'ai vu parce que ça m'a été
signalé merci beaucoup la personne qui
n'a signalé
j'ose imaginer que ça risque d'arriver
sur twitter peut-être sur facebook parce
qu'ils aiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
gaffe être extrêmement vigilant je suis
désolé que des personnes utilisent mon
image pour pouvoir vous sachez en tout
cas vous aurez remarqué ça c'est ça pose
vraiment problème
j'espère qu'avec les personnes qui ont
reçu ces messages ya personne qui a
quitté il ya par son cadeau n'est ni de
non-dits d'infos personnelles 10 numéros
de cartes ça serait vraiment embêtant je
ferme ce chapitre jeu
consent vous si vous pouvez aller
signaler ses comptes ce serait vraiment
top
et merci à vous de votre fidélité et de
votre bienveillance voilà sur ce on se
fait des gros bisous et puis on se
retrouve extrêmement bientôt du coup
pour parler de cet iphone là et puis le
tout un de produits à celui là il ya
celui là et il ya plein de pognon la cci
sera cool je vous embrasse et vous dis à
demain bisous chaos